EDHRec is a tool that collects deck data from
across the internet, and which creates pages for
each commander that contain the cards commonly
played in them. I have spoken before about how
using EDHRec for all of your deckbuilding needs
can lead to decks that are flat, formulaic,
and missing lots of great tools, and I’ve also
spoken about how lots of people building decks
mostly with EDHRec causes a handful of unintended
side effects for the broader commander ecosystem.
These things are true and I stand by them, but
I’ve also seen some players take things too far
in the opposite direction, decrying EDHRec as a
useless tool for anybody but the least creative
deckbuilders, and giving themselves a hearty pat
of the back staying away from it. In reality,
EDHRec is an intensely useful website that
has the capability to make your decks better,
more interesting, even more unique in some
ways—if you know how to use it correctly.
So in this video I want to dial in on EDHREC
as a tool, and talk about how I use it:
when during deckbuilding I use it,
what specific features I like to use,
and things I like to be careful of
to prevent unintended consequences.
To start with, there are two main times when I
use EDHRec during deckbuilding—very early in the
process of building a deck, and then sporadically
closer to the end of deckbuilding. These two
timeframes serve different purposes—early in
the process of deckbuilding, I want to get a
lay of the land. EDHRec is useful as a shortcut
for seeing the most popular, and often the most
powerful, stuff you can do with a commander.
In some cases these will be the flashiest plays
you can do with a given commander—we can see
Fists of Flame at the top of the Zada page,
Curiosity at the top of the Niv-Mizzet Parun page,
and Parhelion II at the top of the Greasefang
page. Even if you don’t intend to use the
stuff at the top of the EDHRec page, it’s
good to know what’s there—if you’re looking to
build a deck around Animar, a popular commander,
it’s good to know that more than half of Animar
players are playing him as some form of combo
deck, because that will impact how your deck is
perceived and what other players will be on the
lookout for. In other cases, the top of an EDHRec
page might be more like the points of agreement
between different builds of a commander. For
something like Atraxa Grand Unifier we see
some popular removal spells and some flicker
cards to repeat the commander’s powerful ETB,
but after that the play-rates of different cards
fall off pretty fast, with players choosing a
variety of different approaches for the specifics
of their deck. In this case, I could go “okay,
I guess I’ll start with flicker” and then
decide the specifics of how I want to do that,
and if I want to be among the roughly 25% of cEDH
players playing Atraxa, judging by this page.
Typically I’ll look at an EDHRec page at first
to see any super obvious build paths that other
people have been doing, but then once I’ve
decided to build a particular commander I’ll
click away for a while. It’s useful to know
the basics of what other people are doing,
but the longer you spend on this unaltered
EDHRec page without looking elsewhere,
the more you’ll get sucked into the stuff on
this page and subconsciously let it decide
what your deck wants to be for you. In cases
when I’m using a top-down approach to build a
deck—basically finding a commander I like with a
card or two in mind—I like to get out of EDHRec
pretty early so that the foundations of the
deck aren’t too heavily influenced by what’s
popular. In the early stages of building a
deck, I don’t really want to know that 47%
of other Imskir players are using Deadly
Dispute, because that colors my opinion
of the card at a stage in deckbuilding when I
want to be exploring possibilities and keeping
an open mind to different options with the
commander. Other players might be different,
but I find that the progression of gradually
building up in cards and plugging in different
scryfall searches as I figure out different
ways my deck could play is really valuable as
a creative step—it’s a stage of deckbuilding
that I want to preserve as much as possible.
Regardless of your exact preferences, if you’re
starting your deckbuilding journey in EDHRec,
I strongly recommend you click away to futz around
with your own thing for a while at some point.
For me, EDHRec comes back into the picture a bit
later once I’ve discovered a fair number of cards
and have a decently strong concept of my deck,
but haven’t fully ironed out an initial draft
yet. Whereas the initial usage of EDHRec was to
get a lay of the land and see a handful of basic
build paths, in this later stage of EDHRec usage
I am looking for specific cards. Scryfall is a
lovely tool, but there are some things it just
won’t hit in any reasonable number of searches.
Dour-port Mage won’t show up in any common
searches you might make for a flicker deck,
and if you’re building a Karametra deck,
self-bouncers like Whitemain Lion might
not even enter your radar if you’re not already
in the know. This is where EDHRec is helpful—it
can help you fill in the gaps with popular cards
that scryfall searches might have missed. Even
if a particular card isn’t showing up on the
EDHRec page due to not being popular enough,
looking at EDHRec can still help you find that
card. If you’re building a cast-from-exile deck,
you’ll probably find a bunch of payoffs for
casting things from exile from scryfall searches,
but a brief trip to the Prosper EDHREC page
might clue you in on the words “from anywhere
other than your hand.” Suddenly, that’s
a whole new avenue to take a stroll down,
and you might find yourself a lovely Memory
Worm—get in here, you funky little guy.
Okay, so at this point you hopefully have a good
idea of when I like to use EDHRec and why I use it
at those times. Deckbuilding is a very personal
process and you may have your own preferences,
but ideally you’ll be starting to get a better
sense of what role the website should have in
your deckbuilding. However, in covering the when
and the why, I’ve so far skipped over the “how”,
arguably the most important part. This
might be confusing to a lot of people,
because on a basic level EDHRec is very easy to
use—you pop open the website, find your commander,
and you’re off to the races. Easy as cake, right?
Wrong! This page sucks if you’re looking for card
choices for your specific deck, because
it includes every deck for a commander,
even plenty that look nothing like the one you’re
trying to build. I think we as EDH players have
a tendency to treat commanders as whole entities,
like characters selected from a grid in a fighting
game. This game is Kardur vs Zur vs Syr Konrad vs
one of the 63 Kellens—what a legendary matchup!
Wanting to simplify this one thing is an
understandable impulse given the intense
complexity of the commander format, but it’s
sadly an incorrect impulse. Decks with a given
commander can vary dramatically one another, and
the more diverse a given commander’s decks are,
the less helpful the base EDHRec
page will be. So what’s the solution?
The answer is filters, which I make very
heavy use of once I’m further along and in
that card-gleaning stage of EDHRec usage. By
default, the website will draw data from all
decks in its database with a given commander,
but the filters option allows you to filter
out decks that do or don’t include a given card.
Now, you could put all sorts of stuff in this,
but the most useful type of card will be what
I like to call “indicator cards,” which are
basically just cards that fit very cleanly in
or out of a given archetype. For example, if we
go to the page of Kellan, Inquisitive Prodigy, we
see a melange of different elements, but the most
prominent ones are things involving clues, which
kinda makes sense given that blue green clues is
an established Innistrad archetype. This
is going to be helpful to some people,
but what if I’m looking for a higher-curved deck,
maybe even consider the inclusion of Keruga as a
companion? In that case this page won’t do much
for me before a bit of filtering, and the one
card near the top of the page that really stands
out as a big-mana option is Map the Frontier,
a four mana sorcery that searches up two basic
lands and/or deserts to the field. And actually,
this works great as an indicator card because
it’s not the sort of card that most decks will
want. Mana ramp past two, maybe three mana stuff
will typically only be included in a deck if it
fits with a deck’s synergies, so its presence
will generally be a good sign that a deck has a
big mana gameplan. Sure enough, that’s reflected
after filtering—we see lots of higher-cost cards
that would require mana investment to succeed,
as well as lots of great tools for a Keruga deck.
So that’s one example, but what about an example
of an anti-indicator card? A while back I was
brewing a Kardur control deck, sort of like a red
flicker deck. A major goal of the deck is to have
a basically unlimited supply of Disrupt Decorums
available, since Kardur has that effect on ETB,
and ETBs can be repeated with a card like Jaxis
that can produce a token copy of a creature each
turn. I thought this was a sensible enough plan
for the commander, but when I went to the EDHRec
page, a number of the more commonly played cards
themselves did goad-related things. Initially I
was pretty shocked that around half of all Kardur
players felt the need to run cards that do the
same thing as their commander, but that’s their
business, not mine. The important thing is what
happened next: I filtered the results. One option
for this could be to filter by cards I know I want
in the deck, such as a couple red flicker staples
like Jaxis and Conjurer’s Closet. However, the
result is pretty muddy, with Disrupt Decorum now
showing up in an even greater proportion of decks.
The issue is that these red flicker cards don’t
do anything to indicate a player who is averse to
redundancy—there are plenty of goadmaxxers out
there who will take the flicker stuff and the
additional copies of goad cards, because they just
like disrupting decorum that much. No, the way to
start sculpting a helpful EDHRec page in this case
is to exclude the cards that do the same thing as
the commander, such as Disrupt Decorum and Geode
Rager, and after that the page suddenly starts
looking a lot more helpful. There’s still some
of this that’s probably outside what my deck
would want to do, but at least the goad stuff
is mostly out of the way—Vengeful Ancestor is
only in 12% of the remaining decks after this
filtering, down from 43% on the base page.
As a final example of filtering, let’s talk about
how to combine includes and excludes. Back when I
had a Liesa hatebears deck, I’d periodically check
EDHRec to see if anything was catching my eye,
but for this to work I needed to filter
the page first. The most popular build of
Liesa is lifegain, and though I don’t mind
a little lifegain to offset Liesa’s drain,
it’s definitely not what the deck is built around.
A first step could be excluding some core lifegain
cards such as Soul Warden, but this isn’t all that
effective because lifegain is just such a dominant
archetype, and there are plenty of lifegain
decks not including a certain lifegain card
for one reason or another. A different approach
is to filter for inclusion of 2 mana Thalia,
which is basically the first card I’d add to any
hatebears deck, and this is a bit more effective,
but lifegain cards still start creeping in
at around 25% inclusion. What works best is
the combined approach; if I filter for decks
that include Thalia and exclude Soul Warden,
lifegain is basically obliterated from the page,
with a Well of Lost Dreams and two Sanguine Bond
effects being the only lifegain payoffs remaining.
This also still leaves a healthy 550 decks, since
I didn’t need to throw a whole bunch of cards into
my filters in order to get the desired results.
You can do something similar with
price if you’re looking for a budget
deck—if a base EDHREC page is helpful
aside from the cards being too pricy,
you could exclude an expensive card
and include something cheap like a
solid budget land. Suddenly, the cards on
the page will be much more in your budget.
It becomes more clear just how important
filtering is when you think about an EDHRec
page as a cross section of a handful of different
overlapping decks. Some commanders will be pretty
straightforward and less diverse—if we go to
the Prosper EDHRec page, there are almost 30
nonland cards that show up in more than 50%
of Prosper decks. Meanwhile, if we look at a
similarly popular but more open-ended commander,
Alela Artful Provateur, that number is less than
half of that, and some commanders like Glissa
Sunslayer have almost no cards above the 50%
played threshold. For commanders with a singular,
more streamlined playpath, the base EDHRec page
can be moderately helpful, but for a more
diverse commander the page might be pure soup,
an unfiltered mishmash of different archetypes
interspersed across the page. I actually made
a video last year about exactly these sorts of
commanders, with Archelos, Francisco/Malcolm,
and Skeleton Ship as examples—these EDHREC pages
of these commanders are equal parts interesting
to dig into and instructive for seeing the
limits of an unfiltered EDHREC page. I’m
also very interested in what causes a commander’s
EDHREC page to be more diverse or less diverse,
so I actually ended up working with my brother
to analyze a whole bunch of EDHREC pages,
and we made a video about it over on my second
channel, complete with a tool to analyze your
own commanders. I’ll include a preview of
that at the end of this video. Regardless
of what exact commanders you’re using,
filters are an important thing to have
in your repertoire if you’re using EDHRec.
The website as a whole is a very useful tool,
both for getting a sense of the broader play-rates
of a commander and for finding specific cards,
but if you’re using it for the latter purpose,
using filters will save you a lot of time and
effort, and also show you more cards. EDHRec
pages will typically show about 300 cards, and
that’s a decent amount if most of the cards are
ones you’d actually consider, but if two-thirds
of them are for disparate archetypes that you
didn’t put in the effort to filter out, suddenly
you’re getting a lot less useful information out
of the page. So, uhh, use filters. They’re good.
As a final note, using EDHREC in general
will likely help your deck out in some form,
but I’ve found that getting the best usage out
of it requires some level of detachment from
the website. Using other resources and giving
yourself a chance to feel out where your deck
wants to go will help in giving ideas room to
breathe away from the constant input of how
popular cards are. When you are using EDHREC,
it’s useful to sometimes take a step back and
remember what the information on your screen
is telling you. The stuff at the top of an
EDHREC page is simply the stuff that a bunch of
people decided should go in their deck. Different
people might be building decks in different
ways and for different reasons than you are,
so a card being up there isn’t necessarily a
positive or negative statement about it, but
it is a very informative one. Even just taking a
bit to think to yourself about why a given card is
present at a certain position on the page and what
sorts of decks it might be played in is a really
helpful exercise that will make you a lot better
at processing the stuff that’s on your screen,
and better at understanding the EDHREC
ecosystem in general. Any tool will be
much more useful to you if you can get a sense
of why it’s going exactly what it’s doing.
Thanks for watching, and thanks to EDHRec for
sponsoring this video. I also want to thank
Archidekt for their ongoing support of the
channel, and its integration of EDHREC’s salt
scores and user-polled combo database can provide
interesting tools for seeing how other people
might see your deck. Additionally, I want to thank
my Patrons and YouTube members for their support,
some of whom are on screen now. As a final note,
The Command Zone just put out a super fun and high
effort video a couple days ago to go with Edge
of Eternities, and you should definitely check
it out if you haven’t already—a link to that is in
the description. With that said, here’s a preview
of the EDHRec analyzer video, which will be over
on my second channel—linked in the description.